how are you doing today sir
i'm doing good how about you listen this
is a great day i'm a huge fan of your
work
every time i get to talk to you uh it's
like a great day
great thank you so um you won't know
this and this is the only time i'm going
to
put myself in this interview but i spoke
to you for togo
at before the pandemic and what you
don't know is
i had seen the movie downstairs walked
upstairs and they threw me right in the
room
i was ready to burst into tears because
of the movie
i was holding tears in and then i'm on
camera with you almost immediately and i
was convinced i was going to start
crying
nice nice people that have not seen togo
on disney plus it is
extremely good and i recommend it to
everyone
great thank you for that yeah i know i
think uh people
might i people enjoy it and i'm happy
for that
when did you think that you made it as
an actor where
like you could do this as a living and
pay your rent
oh god um those are two different
questions
made it as an actor i never necessarily
thought
in those terms but i'm sure somewhere
looking in my mind there was something
similar to that and uh i could do it for
a
living
i mean when i was younger i i started
working when i was quite young in a
theater company
and it was very modest uh living
but i was able to do
only that so that had some degree of
satisfaction that i thought oh yeah i
i can do this but i never never thought
it would be forever and i never thought
it would uh
go into a you know whatever it is
45-year career
yeah what i think a lot of people uh
maybe fail to remember
is so many people want to be actors and
so many maybe get a movie or two or get
a tv role or two but to
manage to do the career that you've done
is winning the lottery
no i'm lucky i'm fortunate for various
reasons
anybody that gets to do this for a while
and still enjoys it and i do
so more and more uh is lucky not to be
pollyanna about it but it's really true
you've been acting for a number of
decades now can you maybe talk about
what it was like making movies in the
80s versus what it's like to make movies
nowadays or how the business has changed
over the course of your career oh that's
a huge conversation but i just
i i think when i first started out
uh there were you know the studios were
still
very strong and they made movies and
they financed movies
that has changed a lot how movies get
financed
has changed a lot also there was a rise
of
uh independent cinema but then
eventually that got
absorbed into the uh studio system
and then as things got more connected
films became minor players in big
corporations so uh
while the work somehow remains the same
i think the business models
not only and we don't even get into
distribution now
and exhibition has changed a lot
did you ever think about directing or
was it something you were never
interested in
i'm never really interested in it
because um i still
love performing and somewhere basically
i you know it's something that holds a
lot of uh
mystery and fascination for me still
because it's
something that you can never arrive at
you can never
be accomplished at it uh it's
it's always different it's uh always a
challenge
and somewhere i'm a guy that likes to
do things i don't like to watch things
and to be a director i think you have to
uh like to watch other people do things
yep i and also it takes you know two
years sometimes to make a move
that's true too i you know i like uh
i like adventure i like the opportunity
uh
to imagine or even
experience other ways of living other
ways of thinking
and performing and working with
different groups of people in different
combinations telling different kinds of
stories or in different kinds of worlds
creating different kinds of words
all those things are very stimulating
for me
and you can do it in a way that's
[Music]
both both craft and personal uh
a director i think has to be responsible
about where things are going and uh
has to take care i'm very conscientious
about you know
collaboration working in a movie i'm
very
disciplined but there's also a part of
me that's a little irresponsible because
to do what i do
i have to be i i totally understand
what's the most time that you spent
debating taking on a role
you know i'm i'm very fast because
um it's like
i'm the kind of guy that answers emails
as they come in
because i don't like stuff sitting on my
plate you know
because i think email's a good example
if you read an email and there's
there's a challenging response if you
don't deal with it right away
think about it more maybe you've better
about it
but you have to keep on going back to it
to read it again
to find it again it's a little bit like
that when someone proposes something to
make
out of respect to them because i i think
it's disgusting how some actors
make people wait for a very long time on
decisions
because i've been on the other end when
i'm helping put together a thing and
i've seen people
hold up productions for months you know
because they don't want to pull the
trigger one way or the other
um i'm fast i i
i i do due diligence
it's not like uh i don't check things
out but
it doesn't take me very long to decide
whether i want to do something or not
i've spoken to a few producers and
directors and they've told me
sometimes they wait six months for like
a big name actor to decide if they want
to do it they rewrite the script
and then sometimes they say no and then
they've spent six months
i am yeah i i understand why that
happens but uh i don't want to be that
guy
and so far and so far i'm not
um did you have you ever turned down a
role
that still haunts you
um yes but i am saying
i mean not really haunts me but there's
some times where i thought
oh i probably
should have done that but that's kind of
ridiculous because
it would have been different if i did it
so if something
ended up very well maybe i would have
been terrible in that movie
uh maybe the movie would have been
terrible maybe you know it's too
hypothetical
but i am aware that sometimes i've
turned down
things that have gone to you know have
given actors careers or
or have been great successes and that's
not lost on me
but i i don't dwell on it because i
didn't do it
that's that's the simple fact so uh it's
it's all just uh
it's all kicking yourself after the fact
for something that
isn't necessarily uh able to be proved
was a
uh negative uh bad choice you know one
of the things that i admire about your
career
tremendously is that you've been able to
um do these hollywood movies but also
these artistic
independent movies and you've managed to
to to do both
so successfully was that always a
conscious choice
through your career that you wanted to
walk these different paths
or and did you ever have like agents or
managers saying you know
you don't do these moves like you could
do i don't know like did you ever get
feedback from people in your life saying
maybe you
want to just focus on the hollywood oh
no
i really haven't i've had very good luck
with uh
representatives um and i've always mixed
it up
it's kind of happened naturally and i
think it was kind of set up by the fact
that
initially i started out as a downtown
basically avant-garde theater
actor and that was my identity and then
people started asking me to be
in movies and of course i enjoyed that a
great deal and i did
once i made some movies i started to
actively pursue movies
but just kind of naturally i always came
back to the theater
and i enjoyed that i felt like the two
different situations broadly different
situations fed each other so i thought
that was important
but at the same time i'm not a guy i
like to work
and i think actors need practice and
uh to learn they have to do things so
i've you know
it's been conditioned a little bit by
what was available to me
you know if i would have had hollywood
at my feet
when i was a young actor who knows what
would have
happened you know but uh it's kind of
been mixed up
naturally because i haven't
i think when it comes down to it i think
i evaluate each
project i really try to say what is this
am i interested in this and all the
stuff
around it i try not to think about i've
seen too
often something that has no pedigree
that i have a deep feeling for can all
of a sudden become a huge success
and also on the other hand something
that has a huge pedigree
and everybody wants to do can end up
being a total
dud so you've got to go with
your instinct and your interests
and your attraction to people and
situations
and that's what will always
keep you and keep you steady i think
because you can't you know films are so
collaborative you can't control
everything
so if they turn out great or they don't
turn out so well
you can't absolutely control that so
you better know why you're doing it in
the first place
and and and i only mention that because
i find pleasure in little tiny you know
gorilla
films that are not meant for a big
audience and i also find pleasure in big
tentpole movies that are made for a huge
audience
you're working with different tools
you're working with different
expectations
but i find pleasure in both of them i am
curious
when was the last time you auditioned
for a role
oh god um
i'm trying to think you know there's
degrees of audition
but a flat out audition probably
most memorably was spider-man
i was making i was i was making a movie
in spain
and uh an english movie that uh
we shot in spain and they sent
uh a casting director to
film me in my uh hotel room doing some
scenes
that's so interesting that that was that
was the last one
well i think i i you know i get to think
uh
these aren't things that you try to
remember but
god knows there's probably roles that i
had to fight for
or i had to be positioned for you know
but but that's not the same as
auditioning
that time i was like literally put on
tape
to convince these people that i was
their guy
where other times sometimes i haven't
been
first choice or or there were some
considerations
and but that all happens behind the
scenes
and they can always look at uh
a number of films to see you know
whether they think uh
i'm their guy or not i actually did want
to ask you because the thing about
spiderman that you made in i believe
2000 or 2001
was that was before the marvel explosion
of the superhero genre
that was well before superhero movies
had taken over the planet
um what was it like being part of that
wave of those first
superhero movies i enjoyed it a great
deal and it was something new it was
kind of risky and it was also
a beautifully personal film for sam
raimi
and also the producers
this was it seems strange to think of it
now but it was risky
nobody knew how to do these things there
wasn't
there were other comic book movies there
were other
super uh uh what do you call them uh
super hero movies but
this felt this felt new in fact you know
some people
thought um were surprised that i wanted
to do it but
it was a lot of fun to do and sam raimi
really uh you know he was sincere
it wasn't cynical it was a it was a very
it was a movie that worked very well
both dramatically and comically and had
a
a good heart to it yeah it was also
super successful one of those things and
then you know they made
the second and the third um i could
spend more time talking about those but
i
i there's so many other things i want to
talk about believe me i can talk about
that um did you watch zack snyder's
justice league the extended cut to see
all your stuff in it
you know i
you haven't seen it
i've been working no it's fine i
when i'm working i have a hard time
uh seeing other movies
unless they're very unless they're very
different than what i'm doing
and also uh my
my involvement in that was really a
cameo i completely got it
you um you were part of the first
aquaman movie
um are you are you doing anything on the
sequel
i know this is a career thing but let's
not talk about that
got it i will i won't press you on that
um
i am a huge wes anderson fan and a
french dispatch is finally coming out
you've worked with him multiple times
what what do you love about working with
wes
oh well he's uh his vision is so
specific
uh and uh he's so much fun to work with
uh he gives you room but at the same
time
he's so precise so that's a beautiful
combination to have
partly because it's no mystery that of
course he's broadened his troop
but when he knows people he has he sees
them in a certain way
and when he builds things around them he
does it very beautifully
very invested and very artful so
uh he sets people up incredibly well
and he's lots of fun to work with and
his movies are
really particular and fun and smart
and uh yeah i i i love
uh using the i love being in the room
with him
yeah also the thing i love about wes is
you know you're watching a wes
anderson yeah it's very very you know
he's
he's a author cinema in the true sense
that uh wes
anderson movie is a wes anderson movie
yeah i agree
uh jumping into why i actually get to
talk to you with siberia at this point
with abel
you've worked with him i think now six
times is it as simple as a text message
like hey what are you doing in july i
might have something
it starts way before that it's like what
what are we doing
what are we doing he's he's always
he's a self-starter and now
we're neighbors in italy and uh
that i i see his place for my place
in the center of rome and we're friends
and we've
been through a lot together and he's
always working
so we're always talking about
what we could do and he asks me
to bring things to him i'm
i'm not so much doing that but
he'll float things by me and then we'll
work from either scenario or start to
build a script or start to think about
you know uh a property or something
we're always figuring something out it's
a it's a constant thing
so it's not so much like hey what are
you doing next july are you available
it's
we're in touch all the time i i
completely get it one of the things that
i like
about siberia and some of the other
projects you've done is
i firmly believe that cinema even though
it's 100 years old
is still in its infancy as far as the
art form there's so many different
things that we can do with it
and i think siberia represents one of
those kinds of things where
it's it's oh there's a lot of open for
interpretation there's a lot of visuals
that you need to connect on your own
um can you sort of talk about that
aspect of the film and also just
cinema in general i think well
one of the reasons why i like working
with abel is he has a good cinema sense
he's attracted to what's good about
cinema
colors time light events
sound he's really plugged into that when
we made siberia we started he had a
bunch of images
of things he wanted to see and he knew
what the basic story was it was like an
odyssey of a guy trying to find peace in
his life
and it was a it was a
a road movie about a guy in search of
himself
um we we started with that and
although there were some scripted
sections
uh we worked very much from scenarios
and
situations and
then we work to find the specificity of
that
uh it's not a normal narrative of course
and it's kind of enigmatic but
i would never call it pretentious
because it doesn't pretend to be
anything other than it is and that is
a dream language a dream logic and the
only thing that
uh strings it together is
that you're with this guy and hopefully
as an actor you feel like you're going
through these experiences
and if you experience them in an open
engaged sincere way something happens to
you and the audience can be with you
in that and they can in some way
experience it as well
so it's not about clinging or or
empathizing or or grabbing onto a
narrative and
hopping on that train and enjoying the
ride it's really
uh confrontation with the audience as
as you're with him confronting all of
his ghosts
all of his uh worries all of his
uh memories all of those things
i i this is a jokey question but bear
with me
did you have a good enough time with the
dogs in the snow in togo that you're
like able
i want to do another movie where there's
dogs and snow
and i'm going to be cold and it's going
to look beautiful
the crazy part is abel started talking
to me about
his ideas for siberia way before togo
so it's just a weird coincidence that
basically
i shot two dog sled movies in a row
what are the odds of that crazy so
really siberia started first
and then later i was lucky to do togo so
by the time
siberia actually got made i knew a
little something about mushing
now having said that the the dog sled
culture of
northern canada where we did togo
compared to
the dog sudden culture of northern italy
in the mountains is very different so
uh it felt the same
but very different there's a scene in
siberia where you are
cutting a fish uh in the snow
you seem very cold what what is it like
doing something like that um and being
around the dogs i mean because
it's very real what you're doing this
isn't some hollywood make-believe thing
no it's it's things it thinks i know i i
grew up in a very cold part of wisconsin
when i was a kid
i was a fisherman when i was kid dogs
are a new thing for me but i must say
that just recently for the first time in
my life i have a pet
what yeah what what type did you
what do you have a greyhound rescue
from the track in ireland so he's a
beautiful dog
and uh yeah i'm i'm learning to be a pet
owner
i that's great have you found that uh it
forces you to go on walks every you know
like you have to do walks
all of a sudden it's a whole different
world yes sir
i mean i'm i'm new to it so it's like
i i i had a child so i remember that
and uh this is my new child
uh i'm just yeah i i was thinking that
if i was around all those dogs filming a
movie
it would be very hard for me not to want
to take one of the dogs home
they're pretty great i mean dogs can be
great but also each dog is very
different
and this dog that i have is very
particular because he's an athlete he's
uh greyhound
i definitely want to talk about uh your
relationship with robert
making um lighthouse getting to work
getting to work again on northmen um one
of the things i love about his work is
the fact that
he really pulls you in and makes you
believe
teaching on screen is you know there's
it's going for the realism of the moment
uh can you sort of talk about uh working
with him and what you love collaborating
with
i think he's a great talent and i love
working with him so much
and he's such a worker and he's so smart
and he's so
passionate about history and he
it's not uh
a pretentious egoistic thing but he's
he's really drawn to research and detail
and he's not he's not
i i don't know he's he's just got a
sixth sense when i saw
when i saw the witch and i thought
here's a period film
but i and i was entering it it never
pointed to itself and
told you when it was or that it was a
period film
or no i was there i was there and i
thought wow that's some trick
to actually make such a um
sort of exotic time-wise and period-wise
film but have me
able to enter it so easily and i felt
like he did that again
with the lighthouse you know i think as
as you know
stylized in some respects as it was you
know
you you were there with those guys and
i think that's a real talent to make a
period film that doesn't point to itself
doesn't brag about its uh doesn't wear
its research on its sleeve
but it's so well researched that it has
deep roots
it has a kind of truth and a kind of
reality
and a kind of logic to it that's not
showy
or or pretentious it's it's all
functional
so there's a beauty of i
call it the practicality of the poetry
that i love that he has deeply in his
soul
so i i look forward i haven't seen the
northmen yet but uh
and i i don't have as great an
involvement i've got a supporting role
in that
but still i think he's a great talent i
spoke to anya
for queen's gambit and when i brought up
and when i brought up northman
her face just lit up and she you know
she talked about how
uh there were people working on the film
who weren't used to his way of
working and the realism and that you
know she was just like this is what
we're gonna do and blah blah blah
um and i know you have a smaller role in
northman but can you
and i know this is a career thing but
can you sort of talk i mean can you
tease a little bit about
what you're excited for people to see oh
just
just him working with that same kind of
detail
but on a much bigger scale this is
huge it's muscular it's radical
um it uh
as i say i haven't seen it so i can't
speak with great authority
but what i saw when i was shooting it
you know the sets the costumes
everything
just i was transported to that world
and as i say
sometimes these kind of spectacular
big period movies
you gotta buy into them you gotta you
know you gotta accept certain kind of
conventions
but with this
you're there you're there you're there i
i don't know what else to say
no no i cannot wait to see it
i'm also a huge fan of guillermo del
toro and
i can't believe i'm saying this but it
was like a year and a half
ago we were talking about nightmare
alley um
so long ago um and listen he is such a
gifted filmmaker
can you talk a little bit about getting
to work with him on that project and
maybe what surprised you about working
oh great he's a lot of fun he's very
fluid
uh you know hold on your hat he works
from a very strong script
but also he wakes up in the morning and
if he has an idea
even a radical idea he'll throw it at
you and you ride with it and that's
pretty exciting
and of course he's um listen i
i really look forward to seeing
nightmare alley uh
the sets were beautiful it's got very
two very distinct parts
there's the part that takes place
largely at the carnival and then there's
another part
that takes place when uh the bradley
cooper character goes on the road and
starts playing nightclubs
so there's two distinct parts i'm in the
carnival park
and the world that they created is
fantastic
it was just a pleasure to come to the
set every day because you entered that
world
and also in that carnival world we had a
carnival family
of all these great actors uh you know
coming together so i don't know it felt
uh it felt very loose but it also felt
very muscular so
i like that combination i saw some
footage from it actually at a
presentation and i saw some of the
carnival footage
and it looked like there was a you built
a carnival set
yeah we did we did you'd go to you'd go
to work at the carnival every day
i am curious what have you been filming
recently what are you going to be doing
this year if you don't mind
saying i just finished a film uh
called inside with a greek
filmmaker shot in germany and the thing
that's interesting about that
is it's basically i'm the
i'm the only actor there's one section
of fantasy sequence where there are
other actors but
basically every day in and out
i it was me and that crew locked in a
house
um shooting this movie so uh
that we just wrapped so it's a little
premature to talk about but i've been
doing that
and uh the other things that i've been
doing lately i
prefer to wait until we're ready for
them to
come out i understand i want to go
backwards if you don't mind um
there's so many questions i don't i
haven't asked you that i wrote down but
you worked for a few months on heaven's
gate if i'm not mistaken
and ended up with just a small role in
the film at the time
were you devastated that you weren't a
bigger part of the movie or
because it wasn't critically a success
back then or commercially a success were
you like i guess i dodged a bullet like
what was your take on that listen
when i was there i had a great time even
though
there was great pressure on the
production because
after about one day of shooting we were
about a week behind
because he was inventing so much stuff
and then
shortly after executives started to
comment there was a tension
but i loved the detail that uh
shimino was working with and there were
a lot of
great actors and uh it was very exciting
because that was like the first
uh hollywood movie i was involved in
now you don't you you know part of the
story
after being there for like three months
after i was supposed to be
there for two weeks because basically
when i arrived he said
ah no no you you're staying with us
we're gonna develop
these characters these unscripted
characters so
when in the end when the people see them
die in the final fight
they'll relate to these people they'll
have some feeling for these people so
you're here
and i'm like yeah but but i told the
theater i'd be back in two weeks and he
was like
hey come on kid this is going to be a
big movie be happy
but anyway i was there for a very long
time
things started to get very tough people
soldiered on
but he was really uncompromising and
really
fun to work with um
and then one day we're sitting in uh
this is a well-known story so i feel
like i'm wasting our time a little bit
because you can read up on it but
but we're sitting in a lighting setup
someone told me a joke
and i laughed and he heard me laugh
and he told me to step out and basically
i was on the plane the next day
so given that i was humiliated by that
i was embarrassed by that but still by
then my my identity was being a
downtown theater actor so it was
embarrassing but
didn't destroy me i just thought wow
that was
that was a non-start of a career you
know
in film um
so when it came out and it was not a
success no i don't gloat
um you know he he was a good filmmaker
and i understand what happened it got a
runway budget and no
somebody they couldn't say no to him and
then they got all
confused by the pressure but and and the
merits of the film are debatable but i
didn't gloat i
i felt bad that uh it didn't uh
you know reach its audience at least in
the states
did you ever see the the two-hour and
19-minute version
or even his original cut that was at 300
something minutes or um
did you have you not seen those versions
i remember going to like the premiere at
the zig field
and i don't know what version that was i
think it was somewhere in the middle of
those things that you say
i remember people joking saying you know
the prints were still wet when they were
coming into the projection booth
but i i that's a long time ago
and uh it's not one of my uh
central memories sure if you don't mind
i just want to ask you one other thing
i'm a big fan of existence
the david cronenberg movie yep yeah i
just wanted barracks great
yeah yeah another fanta listen i'm
you're you've worked with such a gift
i haven't even talked about scorsese or
the list goes on and on and on but
existence is just one of my i really dig
that movie
can you share what it was like working
with david on that
oh beautiful uh you know it was one of
the best
run sets i've ever been on very um
very productive very fun very uh
together
very clear just he's a joy he's a decent
guy
and he's so much fun and
a great cast uh i remember jennifer
jason lee was
was beautiful in it she was great and i
always remember that i she taught me
one thing she reads the script over and
over and over again
and sometimes i've done that as well
just to make it your own you know make
it your own history know it inside out
uh anyway uh
that was definitely i wasn't one of the
principal actors in that but i enjoyed
it so much
and uh it is an interesting movie
a lot of great actors in it too uh
i could keep talking but i'm just going
to stop and say another time
another time thank you i really do
appreciate you doing this
sincerely sure okay cool cool have a
great day
all right yeah you too